a unique game like evolve requires a
very particular developer and that's
Turtle Rock Studios their iterative
process of development to figure out
exactly what the alchemy is to have a
fun asymmetric experience starts off
with an air of mystery and only through
trying and playing their own games do
they figure out how they really evolved
evolve
evolve is all about providing the right
tools for the player to create an
exciting and memorable experience to
accomplish this hurdle rock had a
fastidiously and repeatedly experiment
and evaluate every aspect of the game's
design to make evolve what it is today
when you started did you foresee what it
is now we're able to conceive of this
product as it's you know coming together
in his final months that's kind of
difficult because the game has changed
so much the overall idea is what we all
thought it would be but the details were
not it was just us playing this
fundamentally good idea and then
building on that and making it cooler
and cooler
so you originally only had one hunter in
each class obviously time goes on you're
gonna have multiple versions of hunters
within each class it's really cool to
have that level of variety but that does
start to present you know balancing
issues you know how you started to go
make them very distinct from one another
but also so they could all play really
well together it's about trying to give
the players freedom of choice but not
overwhelm them because there were so
many options and it took so much for you
and your teammates to choose the right
combination to actually get that synergy
that we have now we wanted to guarantee
that you have that and then put the
depth into the character themselves
while evolved with its variety of
monsters and hunters may seem like the
clearest combination arriving at this
result was a long process
monster started out quite differently in
form and perspective and the hunters
were a paper doll like construct of
various equipment what's interesting
though when you look at all the
different hunters for your very first
prototype five months in you know it was
just four guys with assault rifles so
it's sort of at what point did you see
the need to have to have more and more
distinct roles that each player would
have the course of a match once we've
had maybe twelve or fourteen or
somewhere around there pieces of gear
where you spent a long time trying to
figure out what the combination should
be and realizing that there were bad
combinations if you took this piece and
this piece and this piece of gear I
could almost guarantee that you would
lose the game just really bad right if
the team can lose before the games even
started and we need to make sure they
can't make that decision so that led to
classes you need to design your game in
such a way that you're encouraging
people to play the game the way it's
intended to be played
obviously the monsters as they are now
is probably if far removed from sort of
how they started where they were
inception
it's especially crackin which was not a
flying creature for quite a few years
so crackin used to be able to just glide
and you can glide really far but you had
to find really tall stuff to jump off of
in you know what we discovered over time
is that having inherent advantages like
fighting in the k4 Goliath was fun and
interesting having your navigation taken
away from you because there's no tall
objects nearby that just wasn't fun so
that's when we gave him the inherent
ability to get off the ground through
his own power and then Goliath I think
you can see you know obviously the
precedence of you know King Kong and
other you know it's a little bit more
familiar but what was kind of the
journey of taking kind of back that that
core and then making him into something
unique and distinct as he is in the game
Goliath was he was long time coming yeah
we did like six versions of him or
something and I think four of them were
playable in the game so he was a guinea
pig
yeah it was the first one you know
there's a reason that King Kong is a
favorite or you can see the expressions
in his face and you can see that he has
feelings and and interestingly Goliath
needed to be our poster child for the
game it needed to be the one that
everybody related to that when they see
a picture of this monster they know that
means evolve so let's type with a few
examples of things that were
significantly altered during the course
of development I think one of the key
ones because it's still amazing medium
conceit of it is that you know
originally the monsters played from the
first-person perspective and it sounds
like that's something that you guys
wrestled with for awhile before
realizing that if that's just camp work
yeah it's one of those things where we'd
always just envisioned the game all
we've ever built has turned Rock Studios
is first-person shooters you know so we
just always assumed that we would the
monster would be first-person why would
it not that's what we do and so yeah the
monster head cloths first-person and
head and you'd see like their first
version of a Goliath was actually called
scorpion and it was more like a giant
crab and so he had like these you had
these big claws on the side of the
screen and look kind of dopey and they
looked pretty
and there's a lot of problems with that
one it felt like you were a guy in a
suit you didn't feel like you were a
monster you know it felt like you had
these monster gloves on we could have
sold those or something later right way
then the other thing was we had traps
and mines that you're stepping on and
there's all this awareness you're
surrounded by hunters a lot of times and
so being first person you're blind to a
lot of that you know you can't see get a
harpoon in the back and suddenly you
can't move and you have no clue why
right and so we would have text it would
show up on the screen says you have been
harpooned and that's the best that we
could do and so he had all these
problems and we were wrestling with
those problems for a long time and a
couple of the guys on the team took it
upon themselves to experiment with
making a third-person camera and just
seeing what what did that feel like
and that wound up being you know as
controversial across the whole studio
right some people were very adamant
first-person shooter players and felt
like third person shooters are a
completely different genre and it's just
one of those things where we had to just
remind everybody to be open-minded about
it and let's put it in the game and try
it
you guys are starting to see just you
know all those small incremental steps
that you see have has significant impact
inside of the game the best issue with
that game so frequently I mean do you
ever worried that like you know
sometimes like the force and the trees
you having a hard time separating them
yeah we want to get the game in people's
hands as soon as possible right because
that's that's where a lot of our lessons
are learned one thing that's really
important to us and really valuable to
us that I don't know if the community
knows you know is that when the game
comes out it's not like we're done and
we're wash our hands of it and evolve is
out there and whatever launches is the
way that it was gonna be forever right
the game is deep enough and there's
enough strategy that they are going to
figure out things that we've never done
inside of this studio a combinations and
strategies and that sort of thing so for
us it's just more of the same you know
it's just now we've got more eyes on it
we're going to get more information more
data more feedback and so we're gonna
just continue rolling and you know keep
continue to making adjustments
what was the concept of the hunters what
was the core thing that was essential to
sort of flushing them out getting them
the tools that they needed to actually
take down this massive monster and how
to actually fight this monster who was
not developed and designed completely it
already it's so it's like a difficult
problem to solve when you don't know how
to fight this thing that isn't built
there's a fine line between archetype
and stereotype stereotype is a negative
thing archetype is sort of a celebration
we like having characters that you can
kind of fall in love with and get to
know
you